you
[Music]
so I've done a couple of dry runs of
this at local meetups and I picked the
title a while ago but actually I think I
should I should change it so title is
issue we're tracking fail that build but
really I can call this how to get your
product engineering team to care about
data quality and how you can start
building in some of that assurance it's
been really interesting over the last
couple of days hearing people talk about
what they're doing with data and
thinking about how data quality has the
opportunity to undermine that and also
talking I hearing today about how others
are looking out there at their data
offerings and thinking about the
different steps at which they can
introduce data quality protections so
just give you a little bit of scene
setting so I'm wondering who recognizes
this kind of situation so your product
team has been working on products
they're really excited they've been
working on it for two to four weeks
they're they're all ready to go and they
have a little celebration party yeah
it's gonna go good it's gone and
probably someone in that crowd is
thinking did we ever get back to the
tracking stuff and then yeah I'm
certainly I recognize this I've seen it
and two weeks later they go to the data
team and say yeah how's it doing how's
the I can see if you laughs I'm great
I'm glad that it's it's not just me
who's been in a situation and they go
today's team and they say how is it
performing and they say I don't know
what you expect me to do with this data
and yet Emily an event saying replaced
me and nothing else
and so yeah it's good that a few of you
recognize that and you've seen the same
problems and what this is doing like the
implications of this are big is beyond
that moment and in fact what I've I've
observed is divided happening between
product engineering and end dates of
teams we're on the product engineer
inside the cell okay this is the moment
that day to go and start breaking things
in tag manager the dates theme and
thinking what products just gonna roll
it out anyway I don't really know why
I'm here
yeah it certainly is something that I've
seen before so yeah my name is Steve
Kaufman Smith I'm head of engineering at
snowplow analytics we're a date startup
headquartered in London but we have a
fully remote team and customers across
the world we we have built an
open-source they drive line which is six
seven years old now and
as a service we then deploy that into
our customers cloud accounts for them
and I think there's around 150 customers
who we support at the moment and before
we go any further I have a confession to
make I'm quite new to data and in fact
most of my career so far has been spent
in product teams pissing off data teams
so I'm very familiar with the situation
because I I have a wake of frustrated
data teams behind me but I joined snow
cloud 10 months ago and I'm since a
reformed character and I and I really
appreciate what the the trials and
tribulations of a dates team working on
poor quality or poor structured data
that the types of things that they have
to handle so I'm here to say that the
tracking isn't as important as the
feature you're shipping so test it and
that's a message that we need to be
taken back to product teams how product
teams already do quite a lot of testing
around their feature but we just don't
see that extension into the tracking
strategy and it causes a lot of pain a
lot of investment downstream so snow
plow is big on data quality schema
schemas and structured data or a
cornerstone of our offering and we also
have a lot of work around identifying
bad rows so it's keeping that out of the
out of the storage targets and now the
modeling process but also putting it in
somewhere that you can recover it those
of them was was unless it was generated
by a bot BOTS or a spider and it was
something that you intended to keep
we've got we're just at the tail end of
a lot of work on on our bad road format
and allowing a city more more with that
with that bad data
we also offer QA pipelines so whether
it's a customer of ours whether it's
someone in the open-source community
they could spin up a full version of the
pipeline and then they could put that
against their staging environment have a
look at the events going through it and
see whether they're seeing what they
expect before they push it I'll pursue
production but while we have a lot of
automation on the top line there we
don't offer a lot of automation on the
bottom line and and it's nitrous process
so to give you a little bit of context
this could be anyone's and pipeline but
just to show you the the point that we
started from snow plows so on the
leftmost side we have our track
embedded in in a website or in an
application
omitting events to a collector from the
clatter they get put into a stream from
there they get picked up and validated
against the schema repository if they
file validation they'll go through into
the bad stream and an inter very storage
if they pass that step they're going to
enrich just to keep simplify the the
diagram I haven't put all the various
places that something could become a bad
right but it goes through to the
enrichment step into another stream and
then into the later target them into the
modeling phase there's there's a lot
happening there and some of the the
challenges to to the QA process around
this is that this infrastructure takes
minutes to spin up which is impressively
rewind like a couple years and it would
have taken weeks for us to spin it up
manually we've invested a lot of time in
this but it still takes us minutes to
spin up this architecture it has a lot
of steps that we don't need to test so
the vast vast vast majority of bad rows
we find a generated of validation unless
we have an outage down downstream in the
loader and the enrichment step that's
going to going to cause a lot at the
same time but more often not the the
issue is going to occur at validations
there's a lot of steps there if we're
picking up events when they get the
storage target to know where they've
been successfully tracked or not then
yeah there's a lot of things there where
it's unlikely to fail so we don't really
need to test that there it can take
minutes for an event from the moment
that it's been emitted it's at the
moment that it's going to hit the the
storage target we've got many places to
query we've got the bad Rose bucket
we've got the target there's quite a lot
of different interfaces there that we
would have to get our heads around if we
wanted to try and automate this process
and also it's quite costly to run so if
anyone who's done feature driven
development before like you know that
you need your own environment in order
to be able to test against it you don't
want to be running your tests against
the dependency at the same time that
someone else is running a test against
the same dependency because something
they're doing may throw your tests and
vice versa and in feature tests as the
same as data at the moment that you lose
trust in it at the moment you lose it
loses value
and though the the test fails and you
think well I was probably meant to
succeed you probably wouldn't succeed
another day so we're gonna push you out
reproduction is there are some of the
challenges that we had we wanted to
improve our own internal testing
processes so we built something to help
us and this is called snowplow micro we
release it's an open source project we
release this a few months ago now and
it's a smallest version possible version
of a snow plow pipeline specifically the
collector and the validation step so
it's all it is is the collector
invalidation they're the two things that
we receive farm work most often either
non-compliance the track and protocol or
to one of the schemas that you're trying
to track and in that in that application
we have two endpoints that we can query
we actually have three I should put the
other one on here but we have the
ability to see which good events in
which bad events the the snowplow micro
has received and all of those are stored
in memory so this small version takes
seconds to spin up it takes split
seconds for an event to arrive from
being emitted to arriving behind one of
those api's it's very simple to query
we've got one endpoint with or three
endpoints on the same application we
have a good one that shows all of the
good events bad one that shows any bad
events that are received and there's a
third one it's at /all which just shows
us a tally so it will say that we
received 20 events three of them were
bad 17 we're good it's also single
executable which is really important for
flexibility so what are odds that gods
talk about in a minute is about spinning
this up as part of your automated build
process so having a single executable
jar that you can just kind of spin up
anywhere is really important if you then
want to embed that into any automated
test runner and minimal costs as well
it's pretty small you can you can run it
on your laptop no problem you still get
this performance you still get
split-second performance see ya Mike
micro has helped us to unlock and renew
a new style of testing for data quality
that we we didn't have before and what
it allows us to do is to write automated
tests
that's it outside of outside of micro
and outside of the the application on
the site that you're testing and what
they can do is to drive the the website
so has anyone using automated like web
testing framework before like selenium
or Cypress yeah there's some familiarity
say and that what they'll do is they'll
drive the the journey through the
website so they'll behave as a user
behaves and then they'll what they're
designed to do is then to test that the
website acts in the way that you expect
it to but also you can write out some
customer sessions and we're using those
customer sessions to then validate
against micro to see through that user
journey which good and bad events were
sent so the framework that I've been
using to test this with is Nightwatch
jeaious Nightwatch it's one of the
lesser-known automated testing
frameworks I like it because it's cross
browser which is great we're currently
using micro and Nightwatch to test the
impact of ITP which is which is pretty
good and plus we made some changes to
our cloud so recently that were ITP
related so we were able to see whether
that works in in Firefox Safari ie in
Chrome it's easy to extend once you've
figured out how to extend it what the
real downfall of night-watches the
documentation is really poor compared to
the other players in the space but once
you know how to do it is quite easy to
to break it open and to break out of the
normal cycle which is just you know
running through a website and seeing you
know performing actions there and go and
do something else also has by far the
cutest logo so this is a Night Watch
test I this is the shared laptop I've
put this into slides I think word got
around that when I did this over that a
date council meetup in London the demo
failed miserably so I pushed it into
slides so I'll just talk you through the
test a little bit for context so this is
a test that's going to add multiple
products to my my e-commerce stores cart
so the first line there is going to
click the link to see the their shirts
this is the clothes shop and it's going
to change the quantity two to two so on
to buy two shirts the third line there
going to add that item to the cart what
the sites going to do is take me then to
the basket and I want to check that the
shirt is in the basket so under the the
div on the site that has the ID cart I
want to make sure that the text shirt is
in there it's not the best test but I
wanted to make something nice and short
so I can show you how I would extend it
so thinking back to the product team
like they see this test passed right
everything is working like this is
brilliant our feature is complete and
they'll be right if this is all they're
going to test so what we've been doing
using Nightwatch and using snowplow
micro is to extend the Nightwatch
framework to add in this function which
is called no bad events all this is
doing is it's checking that /all
endpoint which returns that a JSON
object that says how many good and bad
events are and then is checking whether
bad event C is equal to zero and if
they'd have run this then they would
have seen that they had 10 million
events saying replace me and nothing
else so yeah this this if you if you do
something like this so it's that what I
want to talk to you about today is snow
plow agnostic is testing framework
agnostic this is really about behaviour
that I think we should start trying to
to inspire and incentivize in in the
product engineering process and if all
they could do is this is to decorate
their automated test with did I send any
bad events this would this would see off
like 50% of the the tracking outages
that we see through through just
invalidates long non-compliance to
schemers so yeah this this could be all
that we asked them to do but we have
extended it further for the you know
really keen teams or the Kings who
really the teams who really care about
data quality so we've also got the
ability through Nightwatch and snowplow
micro to to check whether of the good
events did I receive the ones that I was
expecting to receive so here I've
abbreviated it slightly but I'm
expecting to see two events that are
cart events so this this test would
actually fail in the the site that I'm
testing and the reason is so you know
when I see this if I'm software engineer
and I'm writing this and I go okay that
failed I only got one I should have got
two so I can go back to the the code and
talk to the engineer who
to maybe talk to the day's team and they
say no you've you've misunderstood if we
change the quantity we still send one
event where we send quantity of two as a
value so I can extend my test to make
sure that's true so now not only am i
making sure that I get the that I've
sent no bad events that I've sent that
I'm receiving the types of an event that
I expected to in the right quantity but
I'm also checking the values that are
set within them so if there's any key
bit of data that you really need to
track that this is a really you know
it's a really good investment of time to
put this in there and make sure that
you're going to get that when you come
to use the data maybe when I sit down
with my dad's team they might say hey
your testers passing but you know what
don't forget the context but this is
something that we we taught to customers
a lot about and people in the
open-source community about making sure
that contexts have have been attached to
to events it seems to be an area that
tends to fall down quite often so I may
decide to extend this and this is
actually an array so I can put in lots
of these option objects to to test
whether all of these schemas are there
so it's going to iterate through the
contexts or attach to this the schemas
go to the events and it's going to check
that I have context of a certain type
and I could also check the values of
those contexts as well so in this case
having sat down with the data team
they've told me that not only do I need
one cart event with the quantity of two
is that said as a value I always need to
attach a context of type product entity
that has a value of values in there that
have a name name of shirt and color of
white so so that's just an example
that's the sort of code that I'm going
to show I do have a demo which last time
I checked worked and I'll show you that
in the office hours and I'd be really
happy to show this working because one
thing to note is that I was talking
before about the QA process if you think
about how long it would take to to go
through the website click on the events
that you wanted the click on the journey
that you expected to have wait for a few
minutes for those events to end up in
your storage target then go and identify
what isolate those events and find out
where they
and then go through them one by one and
make sure that they have the right
context attached and those contexts at
the same value no one's going to go
through that effort but of course that
means that we have you know poor data
quality when we come to do our
decisioning at the end all right
analytics at the end so yeah it's this
this process so I'll show it working
during the office hours they you hardly
see it happened though the it spins up a
browser and go through the German web
journey sets against the API I think you
know this this test would take less than
a second to run and when it becomes less
than a second to run people are going to
do it so this goes really beyond
building assurance around the feature
that you're shipping and there's a few
reasons why I say that one is it is not
just about the feature that you're
shipping if you have lots of independent
teams working on their own threads they
might be writing tests as they go but
your test is always out there in
perpetuity being run so you're not only
assuring that your functionality is
emitting the right data today you're
assuring that it's going to be emitting
the right data in perpetuity in the
moment that song breaks it that bill
doesn't go out to production
we're also shorting shortening the
learning cycle so thinking back to that
team they were really happy that they'd
finally pushed out their product their
MVP and they wanted to see what the data
said and how it is performing this is
what the learning cycle tends to look
like so you you have your development
process you desperately add some some
tracking at the end to try and satisfy
the data team two weeks later you find
out it's wrong and you make some
Corrections two weeks after that you
find out it's still wrong and the
process continues and your learning
objective gets further and further out
you won't know whether you're your test
is passing and that's when it tends to
be rolled out to production anyway but
if you define that tracking upfront and
if you sit down with your if the product
engineering team sits down with the
day's team to think to talk about it and
to document it and put it down somewhere
in a way that you can then automatically
test against it and assure that it's
always going to work that way in the
future as you get all that benefit but
it really shortens the learning cycle
because you define the tracking strategy
at the start your engineers all the time
considering that tracking strategy as
they're working and then they watch the
test pass the tests will pass now they
can push the production with confidence
and confidence that in a couple of weeks
they're going to get the answers that
they were looking for so now I'm going
to show you that I haven't spent a lot
of time working with happy data teams
because I don't really know what they
say in this instance but I imagine
they'd say something like best dater
ever and it's really important I think
for us to try and stitch those teams
back together I think a lot about them
what they have to learn from each other
if they can collaborate more effectively
one thing that I've found moving from
product to data is that we're trying to
solve the same problems and it's really
important to stitch those teams back
together and I think you know taking the
same care and attention over the
tracking strategy and there the date
strategy is as you do over the feature
strategy is a really important component
of that so really we want to get to this
position now I know that it will be a
lot of investment for a team to decorate
order their feature tests especially if
they were with with tracking tests
especially if they want to go down to
the level of testing context and testing
which values have said in those contexts
but it's an important investment and
product engineer is already investing in
these other things they're already
investing in linting in unit tests and
features and they should be invest in
the same in tracking if they want the
answer to the question how is my my new
feature doing in a couple of weeks
so if tracking is not okay it needs to
fail the build you don't want to be
pushing that out into production so it's
hoping to finish a little bit earlier to
let you guys go to lunch bit earlier and
I have that's the end of the talk but I
will take some questions now if anyone
has me
[Applause]
thank you very much we were just talking
about how great this talk is because
this is a lot of the challenges that we
face on our respective teams are around
this so I'm actually starting to pitch a
very similar project to in our company
um like within my team for this and I'm
just wondering like what's the best way
to I guess convince product engineers
that you know I it's something that you
focus a lot on your talk but I'm curious
I was like well yeah how do you convince
teams to really bake this into their
development process because it's it's a
big change for engineers all of a sudden
to have to kind of worry about data
they're like if testing data when when
they're developing their product so you
know I'm trying to make the best case
that I can for engineers to focus on
this silica yeah how do you pitch that
yeah it's a great question I and I think
there's there's two main areas one is is
that they're already putting the same
amount of investment in other things
like this what we're suggesting that
they try to do with testing the tracking
strategy is no different to what they're
doing already we're testing that the
feature works so so it's the same
arguments right why invest so much in
unit testing why invest in so much and
feature testing is because once you've
put in that effort it pays back in
perpetuity and also you can then
engineer with confidence that you can
you can move on to your next thing
knowing that you're tracking strategy
was okay and you're not gonna have to
come back and fix it so the argument
there is the same but I think the bigger
argument is do you want to be a
data-driven business like if you want to
be a data-driven business you need to
invest in data quality if you want to be
if you want to have that level of trust
in your data and and the immediacy of
that that decision to push something or
not then you need to make sure that
you're emitting the right stuff up from
so I think it's really those two things
they're already investing the same level
of of time in in other strategies for
exactly the same reasons and if you want
to be a data-driven business they need
to need to take every opportunity to
make sure that you're generating
first-time data quality in your
presentation you mentioned that it would
take a few minutes in this process and
the pipelines
until it reached the target which is the
data warehouse or my question is about
real-time data how do you deal with this
and how do you test the latency and how
do we try to improve that that's
interesting so on the on the phone I
think the question is on the full
pipeline how do you test latency yes we
we have other test rigs that we use
internally for that so we use a tool
called locust which can emit huge
volumes of data but it will spread it
out like a little it's like a load
testing framework and yeah we we there
monitor the pipeline end-to-end to see
there's lots of variables so it's hard
to say like every pipeline will deliver
an event in this amount of time
because it depends what enrichment
you're using it depends what your auto
scaling strategy is whoever sets up our
pipeline whether as a customer or open
source have a lot of options so it's
quite hard to come down to a definitive
number but yeah we we have another test
rig which fires in a realistic data at
the front and then we can measure the
distance between the time the collector
timestamp and when it was loaded and we
we're trying to virtually investing a
little bit more in this now so we're
really looking at the observability of
our estate so what we do at the moment
is that we get a lot of that method
those metrics for our infrastructure but
our applications are the best source of
truth they know the exact moment that
they did something so we're looking to
omit those events out into we obviously
have snowplow pipelines internally as
well so you admit those events out and
then we're aggregating those and showing
our customers the the performance of
their performance of their pipelines hey
thank you this was like really
interesting talk and I echo what they
said that this is solving a very
fundamental problem for I think a lot of
companies especially snowplow micro Suns
awesome I was wondering if there was
anything that also plugs into the
framework which helps with documentation
as well so if the product team is
already investing a lot of time in terms
of declaring what the event should look
like and what they're capturing in terms
like for testing purposes it would be
amazing if that could also plug into
some sort of like auto-generated docume
station four then the people are
analyzing the data so I was wondering if
there was already something that plugs
in their eye or if if that's something
that you already addressed with some of
your clients it's really interesting
it's on the radar so we we have in our
insights UI we call it we we have some
areas where we can socialise things like
schemas but we're really socializing the
thing that the application uses in order
to be able to assert whether something
is valid or not what we're losing a
little bit there is some of the meaning
behind it and that that you know that
gets lost between if you have things
that are turn over you some of my define
the events then two years later they're
not around anymore and you need to
change the event but you're not quite
sure why it was created what the purpose
is how it's being used so we we've had
just had a big focus on data quality you
know one of the things that you want to
focus on next is data meaning so
certainly capturing some of that
metadata around the way that the
pipeline is set up with the way that the
schemas are defined because right now
it's very ad hoc if someone wants to
that around smoke well then they would
need to create their own set of of
documents somewhere but again easy to
lose easy to get outdated so we're
looking to keep more of that on kind of
the habitual path and keep it up to date
so you mentioned snow PI micro is really
at one point I wanted to make the snow
pile microsite if you're rolling your
own pipeline you may have the same
opportunity one nice thing about the
snowplow solution which if you can do
the same thing is that the code that's
in micro for collecting and validating
events is exactly the same code that's
in production so that gives us a high
level of assurance that if it works
either locally when an engineer's
testing it or if it works in the
automated testing environment then it's
going to work in production so yeah if
you're if you're using a snow plow
you've got Micro there if you're rolling
your own try and build the same thing if
you're using a you know hosted SAS
vendor try and pressure them to do the
same thing provide some kind of
interface it's gonna give you that quick
response of how am i doing the right
thing because I really believe that this
strategy is needed
I believe it's over to you and I believe
it's one of the reasons why why we start
and why I've observed and I can saw a
few nodding heads they kind of divide
between data engineering and product
engineering
things right yeah I really like the
approach like really trying to stop like
bad code from happening there on the
first time I was wondering like with a
lot of companies now moving like micro
services and a lot of those also being
event-driven there is like a lot less
distinction between like tracking code
and just like message that the services
are using anyway right like that's
really like necessary for just the
application to work so I was wondering
if you have any views on that and how
this could help on that scenario yeah I
mean the the approaches is applicable so
a lot of the web frameworks where
automated testing frameworks post date a
lot of server-side automated testing
frameworks I remember back in the day
when I have a British Telecom we were
using something called Fitness which is
an automated test running runner for
testing against applications and yeah
it's it's the same approach so we have
one of the benefit of the things that we
accommodate in this no power pipeline is
that we have trackers for iOS Android
and and the web ones that you would
expect to find but we also have a lot of
server-side trackers and the reason is
so that we can start to emit events from
applications as well so if you have for
example a product pricing change you're
not trying to infer that from what a
user might be able to see on the website
you're instead emitting that from the
source of truth and saying this just
happened so yeah you can absolutely do
the same thing against any event that
was emitted by by a server-side
application
[Music]